bonjour à tous je suis séquoia
savez-vous ce qui en député on va le
voir aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'un député un député est une
personne qui travaille à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est un représentant national
le siège de l'Assemblée nationale se
trouve au Palais Bourbon à Paris en
France elle cohabitent avec le Sénat
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
forment le Parlement
comment sont élus les députés les
députés sont élus au suffrage universel
c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont élus par
l'ensemble des citoyens français de qui
est composé l'Assemblée nationale
l'Assemblée nationale est composée de
577 députés élus pour 5 ans par les
citoyens
un député représente une ville ou une
région il parle au nom de la population
qui vit dans le lieu où il a été élu et
rempli plusieurs rôles
avec le Sénat l'Assemblée nationale peut
déposer des propositions de loi qui
devront être votées avant l'examen de
chacune des deux chambres les projets et
propositions de loi sont examinées
d'abord par l'une des 8 commissions
permanentes de l'Assemblée les 8
commissions permanentes de l'Assemblée
sont les affaires culturelles et
l'éducation les affaires économiques les
affaires étrangères les affaires
sociales la défense nationale et les
forces armées le développement durable
et l'aménagement du territoire les
finances et les lois le va et vient des
textes de lois entre les deux chambres
jusqu'au vote d'un taxi identique est
appelé la navette parlementaire
en cas de désaccord c'est l'Assemblée
nationale qui dispose du pouvoir de
trancher
le député a aussi comme mission de
contrôler les actions du gouvernement il
peut poser des questions au ministre
l'Assemblée nationale peut également
modifier la Constitution avec le Sénat
il y a combien de députés à la Réunion
le département de La Réunion est réparti
en 7 circonscriptions électorales bien
distinctes la circonscription électorale
est une division du territoire effectuée
dans le cadre d'une élection il y a donc
sept députés à la Réunion représentant
chacun une circonscription et parmi eux
trois sont des femmes
il représente également la réunion à
l'Assemblée nationale
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui vous savez
maintenant ce qu'est un député à très
bientôt dans un nouvel épisode